EMIL KINER: Hi.
Thank you for joining us today.
Today, we'll be telling
you about what's
new in network security
on Google Cloud.
My name is Emil Kiner.
I'm a product manager on
the Cloud Networking team
and I'm joined by my
colleague, Tracy Jiang, also
product manager on the team.
First, we're going to
start by giving you
a brief overview of network
security on Google Cloud.
From there, I'll
dive into Cloud Armor
and share all the latest
and greatest developments
in the product.
Next, Tracy will take
over and talk about all
of the new things
with Cloud Firewall,
and also share about
our new product offering
around Packet Mirroring.
Security follows a shared
responsibility model
on Google Cloud.
We work to secure our
network and infrastructure
and provide customers the
tools necessary to do so as
well in their own projects.
We enable and
encourage customers
to follow a defense
in depth approach,
and deploy security controls at
various levels of their stack
and infrastructure to
enforce access controls
and ensure data and mission
critical workloads remain
private and secure.
On Google Cloud, we have several
key network security controls.
Starting from the outside
in we have Cloud Armor,
the Identity-Aware Proxy,
and the global load balancers
as our layer seven controls
at the edge of the network.
Cloud Armor, in conjunction
with the global LVs
protect applications
from DDoS attacks.
The IAP is part of our
BeyondCorp line of products
to allow access to internal
applications and workloads
without needing a VPN.
Firewalls, in red,
apply at the VPC level,
and can be used to customize
access for north-south traffic
as well as the east-west traffic
into, out of, or through a VPC.
Firewalls are used to
define VPC boundaries
but can be as
granular as per host.
VPC Service Controls
in blue can be
used to control access
to and from GCP managed
API services, such as BigQuery
or Google Cloud Storage
to or from the internet,
into or out of your VPCs,
or on premise resources.
In yellow we have our latest
offering, Packet Mirroring,
that allows you to deploy a TAP
and mirror packets at the VM
or container cluster boundary
to a configurable collector
destination.
Finally, we also support
sending outbound traffic
through cloud net to enhance
privacy and security, as well
as various interconnect and
VPN configuration options.
With Cloud Armor, customers
are able to protect
their applications
from DDos attacks,
filter incoming
requests by geography,
or most Layer 7 parameters like
request headers or cookies.
Moreover as a web
application firewall,
Cloud Armor contains
pre-configured rules
to prevent and mitigate
the most common attacks
and vulnerability
exploit attempts.
Users have access to
real-time telemetry
in the form of Cloud Logs
containing Cloud Armor's
decisions on a per request
basis, as well as a real time
monitoring dashboard that gives
granular views of allowed,
denied, and previewed traffic.
With Google Cloud Armor,
customers' applications and web
sites are protected with
an unrivaled level of DDoS
protection as well
as a web application
firewall able to satisfy
internal security policies as
well as external
regulatory regimes.
The DDoS protection
Cloud customers receive
is the same that has been
developed over the past 20
years to help protect and ensure
the availability of Google's
own services.
In conjunction with the global
load balancing infrastructure,
we are able to
absorb and mitigate
Layer 3 or Layer 4
network or volumetric DDoS
attacks with no impact
on customer workloads.
This mitigation
happens automatically
far upstream from
customer infrastructure
across all types of
global load balancers,
including the HTTPS load
balancer, SSL proxy,
and TCP proxy.
Users can then configure
Cloud Armor security policies
to enforce Layer 7
filtering policies,
and WAF rules on a per
back-end service basis.
Cloud Armor security
policies can
be used to enforce IP or
geobased access controls,
mitigate OWASP Top 10 risks,
and otherwise filter traffic
upstream of an application
based on layer 7 attributes.
Today, we are proud to
share that a rich set of WAF
capabilities for Cloud Armor
is generally available.
Pre-configured WAF rules can
help mitigate the OWASP Top 10
risks.
We have ported over the
[INAUDIBLE] security
core rule set, introducing
rules to detect and block
SQL injection, as well as
cross site scripting attacks.
Additionally, rules for local
file inclusion, remote file
inclusion, and
remote code execution
are available as beta.
The rest of the core rule
set is targeted for release
over the course of this year.
With geo-based rules, customers
can enforce access controls
based on the source
geography of each request.
IP to geomappings are sourced
from Google's geo-team,
so you can be sure
of its accuracy.
We've also launched an
extensible rules language
that allows users to configure
a custom Layer 7 filtering
policies across request headers,
request parameters, or cookies.
Finally, Cloud Armor is now
integrated with the Cloud
Security Command Center with
Cloud Armor findings being
sent to the CSCC dashboard
to alert defenders
of potential attacks against
protected applications
or websites.
We have recently
greatly increased
the flexibility of a
Cloud Armor deployment
to protect an expanded set
of customer infrastructure
on GCP, as well as in hybrid
use cases located on prem,
or in other cloud providers.
Cloud Armor now supports
protecting Cloud CDN origin
servers by enforcing
Cloud Armor security
policies on dynamic requests,
as well as cache misses destined
for the CDN origin server.
Customer applications
are often complex,
serving both cacheable
static content, as well as
dynamic requests from
the same services.
With Cloud Armor able
to inspect and filter
requests destined to
CDN origin servers,
users can now mitigate
computationally expensive
cache-busting
attacks, as well as
help protect dynamic portions
of websites and applications
from the OWASP Top 10 risks.
Enterprises often need to
enforce a consistent set
of security controls
to their applications,
no matter where they are
deployed, whether they
are migrating to GCP or
running in permanently hybrid
configurations.
We've recently launched support
for internet network endpoint
groups that allow customers to
leverage all of Google's Edge
infrastructure, including our
global load balancers, cloud
CDN, and Cloud Armor to protect
their website or applications,
no matter where they are hosted.
Now Google can help
protect your applications,
whether from DDoS attacks
or other common web
attacks without customers
having to deploy
their infrastructure on GCP.
Finally, GKE ingress
support for Cloud Armor has
reached general availability.
GKE users can help protect
their containerized workloads
by placing them behind
Google's global load balancers,
and configuring Cloud Armor
security policies for layer 7
filtering and WAF use cases.
With that, I'd like to
hand it off to Tracy
to discuss Cloud Firewalls.
TRACY JIANG: Thank you, Emil.
In the next section, we're going
to be going through the Cloud
Firewalls.
First, we'll give you a quick
introduction about the DPC file
rules.
Then we're going to be
talking about two new modules
that we recently brought
to market to strengthen
our firewall offerings.
Google Cloud Firewall has
a different architecture
than the traditional firewalls.
In a sense, it does
not have a physical box
that you need to configure
and pipe your traffic
through for filtering.
Instead it is offered
as a virtual firewall
service that is fully integrated
into Google SDN fabric.
The policy enforcement
happens on the host
for each individual
[INAUDIBLE] instances.
Compared with a
traditional model,
this type of architecture will
give you higher scalability
and has no choke point.
It is a fully scalable
and stateful firewall
that inspects both ingress
and egress traffic.
Users can also make use of the
network TAC service account
to define the fine
granular firewall rules,
and implement their micro
segmentation strategies.
As we know, the VPC Firewall
operates at the VPC level.
It allows users to define an
independent set of firewall
rules for each individual VPC.
This gives you,
the project owners,
a lot of the independence
and flexibility
in controlling your
firewall rule set,
and operate in such a
dynamic cloud environment.
However, it does
present some challenges
for corporate security
teams in large enterprises.
This type of
organizations typically
has hundreds, sometimes
even thousands
of projects and networks
in their same organization.
Often times, they want to
implement some common rules
across all the networks
and the projects.
Without a central control,
it's typically very difficult
to do so.
Also the project
owner oftentimes
do not have an [INAUDIBLE]
depth of security knowledge
as their security team does.
Therefore, they could
make some mistakes,
and misconfigure
their firewall rules,
and then expose their
workload at risk.
How to maintain a dynamic
and safe cloud environment,
and strike a delicate balance
between control and dedication
has been the constant battle for
those central security teams.
Hierarchical firewall policy,
we introduced precisely
to address this
type of pain-points.
With hierarchical
firewall policies,
users can define and
attach firewall policies
at higher level
off the hierarchy,
specifically
organization and folder
nodes where the
centralized control can
be defined and enforced.
Firewall policies is different
from a traditional firewall
rules.
It is a container that can
contain multiple firewall
rules.
In there it can be
defined once, and then
later attached to different
nodes in the hierarchy.
Also, when you try to
modify the rule set
within a central
policy, you can actually
execute it in a batch mode.
With firewall policies
attached to a different level
of the node in the
resource hierarchy,
they follow a very strict
enforcement sequence from top
to the bottom.
All traffic must pass the
org level security rules
before they are being
evaluated at the folder level,
and then eventually
at the VPC level.
This type of model made it
impossible for project owners
to bypass or overwrite
security policies set
by the central team.
They also make sure that any new
project and new networks added
to the organization
can be protected
by those central
policies from day one.
Defining rules at the
org and folder level
doesn't mean that
all those rules
must apply to all
instances in the same way.
The user can actually use
target service account
to designate certain
instances for selected moves.
For example, a user could
define a firewall rule
sitting at the org level that
forbids all the egress traffic
and only allows the egress
traffic for a selected
set of proxy servers
that with certain service
account associated with it.
Another module that we recently
be brought to the public beta
is called Firewall Insights.
This module is introduced
to help our customer manage
complex firewall rule sets
in a large VPC environment.
Many enterprise
customers face challenges
in maintaining a clean
and robust firewall
rule set over time, and
face many challenges
such as massive volumes.
A VPC can have hundreds,
or even thousands
of rules associated with it.
Overgranting is another issue.
The lack of visibility into
the [INAUDIBLE] usage data
is typically very difficult
to find them out and eliminate
those type of risks.
Human error is another
factor that could introduce
misconfingured firewall rules.
And outdated rules
were the ones that
left over by the
previous project
and never gets cleaned up.
With Firewall Insights,
we introduce a set
of capabilities that hopefully
will help our customer better
manage those challenges.
First, we introduce a set of
metrics for firewall usage,
such as the hit count
and last hit time.
Using these metrics,
users can easily
find those allow rules that
are not used, and clean him up
in order to tighten
the security boundary.
During troubleshooting
time, users also
can make use of those
rules to know precisely
which rules are being hit when
certain traffic pass through.
It can also detect
abnormal traffic patterns
by observing sudden
jumps in their hit trend.
All those metrics
exported to Stackdriver
where a user could use them
to create custom dashboard,
define user found
alerts in order
to catch conditions
they are interested in.
Firewall Insights
also brings a module
that automatically scans
the entire project for all
the firewall rules and
detects shadow relationships.
A shadow rule is a rule
that is overshadowed
by one or more rules sitting
at a higher priority.
Without machines help, it's
typically very difficult
to find it out manually.
With Firewall Insights we report
centrally for all the shadow
relationships in a project.
And we refresh that periodically
so the user could simply
go through the report, examine
each shadow relationships,
and eliminate them as needed.
Next, we're going to
talk about the new module
that we recently brought to
market called Packet Mirroring.
So what is Packet Mirroring,
and why do you need it?
As we know that to build
a robust threat detection
program, we need the combination
of the network's threat
detection system
combined with EDRNC
to give us the critical
visibility that
enables quick, swift
investigation and response,
and then minimize the
damage during an attack.
Network data is often
considered a [INAUDIBLE]..
It provides complete visibility
of the network activities.
It's really to
difficult to evade,
and cannot be easily turned off.
During an attack
when an infected host
is trying to reach another
host, the moment a packet leaves
the host, it will leave the
trace in your network data
which will be captured.
Therefore it's often considers
a very reliable data source
for threat investigation.
Many of my enterprise
customers are already
taking advantage of this
set of data new setup tools
to collect to and analyze
this data for their security
purposes.
When moving to the public
cloud, they sometimes cannot get
the same level of visibility
into their network traffic.
However, when they are
moving more and more workload
into the cloud, their networks
start to become very complex.
Therefore, they
demand the same level
of visibility for the network
traffic, for performance
monitoring, and security
control purposes.
GCP Packet Mirroring
is introduced precisely
to address this type of need.
They help the user increase
their confidence in their cloud
migration and ensures
a smooth transition,
and gives them the
ability to implement
advanced and proactive
security contracts.
GCP Packet Mirroring
is now generally
available in all regions
for all VM instance types.
It can help capture traffic
from all different directions.
Traffic between VM
to VM, between VM
to internet, and also between
VM to Google services.
When combined with
intrusion detection systems,
it can help users easily detect
abnormal traffic patterns,
and capture the emerging risk.
It can also help them satisfy
the compliance requirement,
and also used for
application performance
monitoring and
troubleshooting purposes.
Now let's take a
look how the Packet
Mirroring works under the hood.
Packet Mirroring can be enabled
for both GCE-VM instances as
well as GKE clusters.
It happens at the
instance level.
So whenever the Packet
Mirroring is enabled,
it captures all the traffic,
both ingress and egress,
including the header
and the payload.
To configure a
Packet Mirroring, you
need both front-end
and back-end policies.
The front-end policy will
define which instance will be
enabled for Packet Mirroring.
You can specify a specific
individual instance
to be activated.
You can also specify
a group of instances
by specifying the
subnet or using
network TACs The back-end policy
specifies where the collector
endpoint is.
A collector endpoint is
an internal load balancer
that sits in front of a
group of collector VMs.
The collector VMs
usually are running
a set of partner solutions, such
as the Parardos IDS systems.
When the policy is defined,
the Packet Mirroring traffic
will be piped through the
internal load balancer
into these collector VMs where
the different systems will
consume those traffic to
perform different type
of functionalities.
We recommend that you
use instant templates,
and manage instance group to
manage these collector VMs.
It will give you auto-scaling
and auto-healing capability,
and help you meet traffic
demand, and availability
requirements.
Packet Mirroring can be
configured in your API,
and G Cloud command.
It can also be triggered and
enabled through the [INAUDIBLE]
functions.
While Packet Mirroring
provides critical data,
it enables a set of
critical use cases.
It won't be the
complete solution
without our ecosystem
partner's support.
Therefore, we have
built an ecosystem
with vendors coming from network
security and network monitoring
domains so that our customers
could make use of the tool
that they are familiar with to
consume those Packet Mirroring
traffic and build a solution
to satisfy their needs.
To learn more about the
network security functionality
that we just went
over in this session,
here are a list of resources,
including blogs, documentation,
a live demo, and some
other next sections
that you'll want to refer to.
Thank you very much for
joining this session today.
We hope you enjoy
the rest of the show.